-We have such a great show
for you tonight.
And you know what?
Before we go on, I'm a little
hungry. Do you guys mind?
I'm just going to grab
something from
the "Tonight Show"
freezer really quick.
It'll just take a second.
So sorry about that.
Just got hungry.
Thank you, thank you.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
No! No!
I'm stuck!
Someone help!
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in the freezer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's no use, Jimmy.
It's no use.
-Mick Jagger?
What are you doing here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I ate a bunch of gazpacho,
and I needed
to find a place to cool off.
-But gazpacho is cold.
-It was a hot gazpacho.
-This is awful.
I knew that buying a soundproof
freezer was a mistake.
We're doomed.
-Yes, we are doomed.
Well, since this
might be the end,
I have a few secrets
to share to get off my chest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Same.
When I text someone
"Sorry, I just saw your text,"
I'm lying. I saw it right
when they sent it.
-I know.
I have a secret
to share with you.
-Yeah?
-One time I did get
satisfaction.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Way back. Way back in 1992.
-Really? From what?
-Popping bubble wrap.
It's just so satisfying.
-I still cry
when I use no tear shampoo.
-You know, I want to tell you
my real name.
It's not Mick.
It's Rick.
One time a barista got it wrong
and I was too polite
to correct her.
It just got stuck.
-It stuck, yeah
[ Cheers and applause ]
No one really knows this,
but my laugh is fake.
Because if anyone heard my real
laugh, it would ruin my career.
-Can I hear your real laugh?
-I guess since
it's just us in here.
[ Dolphin calling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I get it?
-Yeah.
-Let me tell you something else.
I never really liked
going to Studio 54.
-Why not?
-Well, there's a much
better club next door.
-What was it called?
-Uh...
Studio 55.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, being a late night
host actually
wasn't my childhood dream.
Like a lot of comedians, I
always wanted to be a rock star.
-That's weird.
I always wanted
to be a comedian.
-Like me?
-Yes.
Like you, but funny.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Mick Jagger
called me funny.
[ Laughter ]
-I never told anyone this
before,
but I'm Banksy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, sometimes
after a long run,
I sprinkle pop rocks
in my undies.
It's the only way I can feel.
-I actually do a good
Jimmy Fallon impression.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I hear it?
-Sure.
[ Dolphin calling ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-What are you guys
doing in here?
Oh, my God, it's Higgins!
We're saved!
-Oh, my gosh.
Mick Jagger.
Would you -- would you
sign my "Hackney Diamond" album?
-Of course.
-Here you go.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is great.
-He's gonna sign it for you.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-Yeah, cool.
-Wait, it says Rick.
-[ Blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-This has been...
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show" after the break.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]